[Music]
hey guys what's up what's up how's
everyone doing great a little nervous
definitely a little nervous no God no
I'm so stoked
[Music]
all right okay guys I say the one that's
in the middle unfortunately he is fine
top okay yeah agreed hi
[Music]
we'll start there
all the way do you think women often
find you attractive uh yeah
so why why did you put him first I feel
like I saw his smile the smile was nice
he's tall and he has like really nice
hair and he's tan what are you looking
for in a man physically
[Music]
um definitely someone who's tall taller
than me that's for sure definitely good
teeth says a lot about personal hygiene
if it looks like you haven't brush your
hair in a day or two someone with bad
hygiene that's just immediately you
don't take care of yourself and I don't
want to be near you I like Smiles I like
eyes and energy maybe like demeanor like
how they're standing I think blue shirt
needs to be second or I agree because
his face is really symmetrical yeah
yep
let me just see yep yep
okay this one has Personality yeah he's
like unbothered I really like him look
at his shirt guys yeah it's giving
Shaggy from Storage I really like look
at the chain too Jack is giving Jack is
giving yeah
I think I got like a pretty nice face
like my nose was really like everyone
says I got a cute nose I like this dude
he's quiet and he's here yeah
that's my favorite for people I would
say that like I'm very middle of the
road Here I Am the Only
short hair white guy so that's like kind
of set me out of the group it was like
oh the oh look vanilla ice cream right
there I feel like we can leave them how
they are yeah
sweet like I just want to protect him
like he looks like a baby then like I
feel like I don't know okay let's try to
switch this one and this one and see how
that looks which one which one
you green shirt to the end let's see how
that looks and you switch yeah how do
you guys feel about that because style
um I I think Andros is second for me
I'll say it again yeah honestly yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I think just like look wise I think
First Impressions yeah nothing personal
how did you feel during the physical
round uh I loved it I love when people
are judging me made me feel good even if
I wasn't at the top it was just like
yeah they get to look at me it was
honestly good for them they got to look
at some beauty over here
can everyone introduce themselves name
and what you do yeah
uh and I model I'm Wes I'm a student and
model
I'm Andros and I run a tech company
about an accent
is that an accent yeah yeah what do you
think it is I have no idea but I like it
Jack I'm an actor and I coach volleyball
I'm Nick I'm a painter and a I make
furniture
[Music]
very attracted to humor humor that's 100
I like someone who's funny and who can
take a joke because like I've had
experiences with super serious men who
just they take everything personal if I
hear any sort of bragging or any sort of
I've got this I made more than I don't
want it I already stopped listening
someone who's cocky I think it's
important to be confident but it's very
there's a very clear distinction between
the two hey Grace what do you find
attractive in someone I mean personally
I love it when guys care about the
quality of products they use I've never
actually thought about that but you know
what it makes sense when someone cares
about the quality of their products and
doesn't fall for marketing gimmicks
that's really attractive oh my gosh
sorry I'm late I couldn't help but
overhear your conversation can I just
add cleanliness specifically a good
clean shave wait duh of course you can
okay perfect I'm so glad because we want
to thank Henson shaving for sponsoring
this portion of the video did you know
that Henson pivoted from making airspace
parts to making razors like their al-13
during the pandemic guys I use Aerospace
Precision on my skin it's not just for
men women love it too with Henson you
can even eliminate the excessive waste
caused by plastic disposal razors
because the al-13 and their blades are
plastic free wait does that mean yep
they can even be recycled the
replacement blades are also like 30
cents per month so you don't have to
worry about spending a ton of money on
shaving as long as you have a Henson
razor and who doesn't love saving money
so whether for you or a friend or anyone
who wants a smarter shave Henson is for
everyone click the link in the
description box below and use code
Jubilee for 100 free blades with
purchase of any razor that's up to four
years worth of free blades thanks so
much to Henson shaving for sponsoring
this portion of the episode now let's
get back to the video
um what's everybody's favorite movie
everything everywhere all at once okay
that's a really good one teaser the sun
okay it's about um the war in Africa How
African nations go against each other in
U.S force went over to save um so um I
think it was a princess hurricane
there's a really deep one okay okay
he seemed like he was very nervous but
nervous Synergy was a little bit
off-putting so that energy just didn't
match I would say Game of Death is like
an old Bruce Lee movie it's like the
first movie I ever saw with my dad wow I
really like the SpongeBob movie
I watched that like every month oh my
gosh yes uh drive that's also a good
movie okay I'm gonna be that person
what's your zodiac sign I'm a Libra okay
I'm a cancer
are you just asking for sun not like oh
I'm Aries son sagin Boone Taurus Rising
oh my God okay I'm Sagittarius but my
sister knows all the other stuff the
rising it's all my flowers once you say
Sagittarius I was good
should we go deep when's the last time
you cried I was watching a medication
commercial for uh like back pain and
this woman was like in a hospital bed I
was like
[Music]
it's a I cry at commercials and yeah
last time I cried was Marley and Me I
can't do that if I ever see it complete
uh I watched this film called past lives
recently yeah I cried at the end scene
it was it was it was crazy now we have
to watch it yeah you do
yeah he's trying to cry now no I lost my
best friend this year so it's still been
hard thing for me I'm so sorry
you may be thinking about it
oh my God can we give him a hug can we
go give him a group hug oh my gosh
so sorry
I feel so bad because the tissues oh my
god oh I'm so sorry man
it's hard I'm back on drugs
that was my brother
damn whose question was that no I'm
sorry I'm kidding I'm kidding okay
and you oh mine was like I think last
week I think it's at the movies I was
watching a movie okay which one the
stupidest reason it's Blue Beetle it had
something to do with family
so hard that makes sense I was like damn
and I cried like three times in that
movie I think it's respect though
okay what's your um what's your buddy
count okay
okay
I think ten together
I think I'd you know I don't want to
think of each one as like a number so
yeah
I want to keep that project
can you pick up his answer and I lost
track okay
is a crazy response
I didn't I never I never I never counted
this I never kept like he's like
the points like in my head mentally now
I'm counting okay Nick you've been
reacting to hear it it's interesting
what what was your reaction one that you
didn't want to think if everyone has a
number uh I would like to ask you when
the last time you got tested for
anything was me yeah just out of safety
dude like keep track
March okay there you go I'm just saying
that's what I thought it's like what the
heck
no no sorry it's no people are people
and not just numbers obviously but I was
just I'm just saying like all right yeah
it's better much better I gotta keep
track in my head because I forget things
all the time yeah so it was a little bit
dramatic for me
um and that was coming from the quiet
guy so I was just kind of confusing
um I'm kind of with that you should get
tested I mean I think the delivery kind
of came out a little harsh I didn't mean
to impart any judgment upon him for that
at all I was just thinking like um it's
like oh well I mean yeah dude everyone
here thinks women are people like I
think that's we all agree like no
they're not just numbers they're not
like wins but if someone's asking you
the question I was thinking like well
what's the rough answer yes sorry
totally
oh oh oh okay no I don't really care
it's it's I don't care uh like 27 28.
okay
um who pays on the first date
oh yeah yeah I would honestly I will
make some more money
I think it sometimes depends on who
invited to but most of the time it's
like in a heterosexual setting it's like
the guy inviting the girl so with Andros
I felt like he had Direction in his life
he just screamed providerman mindset and
that's something that I'm very attracted
to what do you feel like is something
that you struggle with the most that
you're like working towards fixing that
has prevented you from like healthy
relationships
I can say I lost myself at one point in
my life um just going through a lot of
hardships especially with my grandma
when she died I just kind of lost myself
in the Wilds lost myself in the sauce so
I can definitely say I was toxic to a
certain greed couple years ago
I think mine is more of like asking for
help because I grew up an only child
until like maybe a couple years ago and
also growing up my mom was always
working so I'd come home alone and do
everything myself like communication is
like my number one factor if like you
can't do that then there's not going to
work here I think for me I tend to
dedicate a lot of time at work and so
sometimes I think my ex would say that I
neglect them or I don't spend enough
time with them and as I'm getting older
I think I'm realizing that you know
having a healthy relationship actually
really helps with your Ambitions you're
an Aries I'm an Aries that makes sense
yeah uh when I was young I was like kind
of dumb and I didn't realize talking and
doing stuff with other girls was as bad
as it like could be you know I didn't
cheat or anything was calmed down I saw
your face but I was just like just like
you know like hanging out with girls and
not being like vocal about it I learned
that was like pretty bad and they're
like you know just messed that would
like that's what all my exes would say I
don't know I definitely like
um I get like pretty bad seasonal
depression and I'm like I'm gonna go
crawl into a hole and die
um and then I'm not really there for
everyone in my life so working on that
has been like a big thing
is everyone here single yes yes for the
most
part
she's gonna watch it no she knows
we're talking I communicate things
do you guys believe in monogamy yeah
yeah
I think the way our generation is going
marriage is kind of dying out you don't
need to be married with somebody it's
just like someone that you trust and
have a good relationship with that you
can build a relationship and it's like I
do believe in like one person finding
another person when they could be
together for as long as that happens and
then maybe one day they break up or end
things who knows
it happens it's realistic
[Music]
okay so number one I said he should be
at the front at the beginning number two
um he's very attractive but he knows it
number three funny I said I like funny
guys Vibe with his looks and his
personality and his job definitely
someone I'd actually be interested in
getting to know outside of this I
really didn't agree with a lot of his
views on stuff which is fine like you do
you it's just not for me and then
like mildly uncomfortable which is
nothing against him
yeah my number one has energy in line
with like men that I'm usually attracted
to number two I really think he's very
interesting and cool in a way that's not
someone that I would usually be
attracted to but I am and then the
bottom it's not like I dislike anyone I
just I'm very disinterested in a lot of
people and so I think it's just like
it's just like you guys are cool so my
number one it's because he's giving a
sense of stability so he's giving like
more daddy Vibes and I really like that
um number two it's because it just
sounds fun in my vibes so I think we
would get along and number five it was
the exact opposite of why I chose the
first one
yeah
this one because I can learn a lot from
him and I feel like I won't get annoyed
number two I like the quiet I like when
you know men don't have to interject or
talk you know steal this show number
four
um I really appreciated his honesty and
vulnerability
episode of ranking if you are then make
sure to like this video And subscribe
for more now let's get back into the
episode
okay
so
fifth we have West
at seven points
[Music]
in fourth
we have Kai yeah I told you
I told you
Kai you had 13 points I love it and
third
Nick
no way
at 15 points second
Jack at 16 points like Mama we made it
thank God and in first Andros at 24
points what
yeah
yeah thank you
[Laughter]
what use type two and it was everything
no why but okay thank you that's very
kind she's like yeah
yeah
how's everyone feeling I feel fine I
don't feel better feeling good the mid
white guy made it to the middle
[Music]
I wish for her one I would put gingers
too all right
go go keep going keep going go there we
go yeah perfect I think there were some
questions like about tracking this and I
answered it like if you know you're
pretty it's like apparently it's
unattractive now which I never really
agreed with because like I'm not gonna
go around the world thinking I'm ugly
like I know I'm an attractive person I'm
gonna own up to it I'm not gonna be
cocky about it but you know but also the
monogamy question I'm pretty sure threw
them off and probably the body count
threw them off because I know like 27 is
like a high number